get secured the jobs and support the
family and as a women my place first had
to be home but I don't give up I sign up
for a two years program to become a lady
health visitor then I hear about 30
puerile development program a nonprofit
organization working to empower rural
communities I sneak away I travel five
hours to interview for a position it is
first time I am farthest from my home I
have ever been I am processed to my
freedom I have ever been luckily I got
the job but hardest part is to facing my
father relatives are already is killing
him about her dad his daughter went ling
of teasing him with talk of a daughter
crossing the border when i returned to
home i want nothing to more than just
accept the position in her deep so that
night I picked my all things in a bag
and I walked into my father's room I'd
said him tomorrow morning bus is going
to come in if you believe in me if you
believe in me you would take me you
would wake me up and take me off at the
bus station
if you don't I'll understand then I go
to sleep next morning my father was
standing beside me to take me off at the
bus stop
very they they I understand the
importance of words I understand how
words affect our hurts how worse play an
important role in our lives
I understand words are more powerful
than fighting a TI DP I saw there was a
Pakistan which I didn't know a country
much more complex that I had realized
till yet I thought I had a difficult
life but here I saw what women in other
parts of Pakistan were experiencing it
really opened my eyes
supermen had eleven children but nothing
to feed them forgetting water they would
walk three hours every day to wells
nearest hospital was at least 32
kilometres away so if a woman is a
laborer she travels by camel to get
Hospital distances great she may die on
her way so now this became more than
just a job for me I discovered my pavo
now as I was getting salary soil I
started sending back money to my home
relatives and neighbors were noticing
this now they started to understand the
importance of education by the time some
other parents itzá started sending that
doctors preschool slowly it became
easier as an acceptable for young women
to be in college today there isn't a
single girl out of car school in my
village
girls are doing jobs inhale site even in
police life was good but somewhere in my
heart I realized that in my region
beyond my village needs further chains
this is also time when I joined at
UMaine fellowship here I meet leaders
like me across the country and I saw
they had taken risks in their lives I
started to understand thee that lead
what leadership really means so I
decided to go back my region and take a
position as a teacher in a remote school
a school where I have to reach by bus to
us traveling in every morning and
evening though it was hard but on my
first day I do I took right decision
when first day I walked into school I
saw all these little sham imps is
staring back at me with with dreams in
their eyes same dream of freedom which I
had in my childhood so girls are eager
to learn but school is understaffed
girls sit hopeful learn nothing and they
leave
I can't we had to see this happening
there was no turning back I found my
purpose I understood few of my friends
to help me to teach I am introducing my
girls with outside the word by extra
curriculum activities and books I share
with them the profiles of world's best
leaders like Martin Luther King and
Nelson Mandela last year few of our
restaurants went to college for me I
never stopped studying
are you working to complete my PhD in
education which will allow me to gain a
management position in a school system
and I will be able to take more decision
and play an pivotal role in this system
I believe without educating the girls we
may not make this word peace we may not
reduce child marriage we may not reduce
infant mortality rate we may not reduce
maternal mortality rate for this we have
a to continuously
and were collectively work together at
least I am playing my role though
destination is not close road is not
easy but I have a dreams in my eyes and
I am NOT going to look back now thank
you
[Applause]